The family of a North
Carolina
man is suing Google,
accusing the tech giant of negligence
after their loved one died
allegedly because of Google Maps.
Phillip Jackson's
wife says her husband
was driving back home from her daughter's
birthday party last summer.
His family says he was following
the app's
GPS directions on a dark and rainy night,
which led him to
an unmarked, collapsed bridge
that he assumed was a safe route
because of the GPS directions.
This is what the bridge looked like
in the daytime.
Instead, he fell to his death.
The lawsuit claims Google had received
notifications from area
residents about the bridge,
but failed to update its maps.
Now, Google has issued a statement
that reads,
We have the deepest sympathies
for the Jackson family.
Our goal is to provide accurate
routing information in maps,
and we are reviewing this lawsuit.
The family is also suing
Google's parent company,
Alphabet and two local companies
for failing to maintain the bridge.
CNN has asked for comment
from those co-defendants as well.
So joining me
now is Alisha
Jackson, Phillip Jackson's widow.
Alicia, I just want to start with one.
I'm so sorry for your loss.
I'm so sorry that this happened,
but that your husband
was leaving
your daughter's birthday party.
You had left earlier.
What did you think
when she didn't come home?
How did you tell your two daughters
Well, I thought
first that
he was sleeping on the couch
when I woke up, so I didn't really rush.
But when I came downstairs,
saw he wasn't there,
and I was kind of confused.
And my daughter came down
and asked, where's daddy?
And I said, I don't know.
And she started to cry.
So I said, no, no, it's okay, honey.
You know, Daddy,
I'm sure he's helping somebody now.
He does.
Somebody needed to use the truck.
And then I kind of went in the back room
and started calling my friends and
asking when he left.
And they
said, we'll drive the roads
to see if we can find him or anything.
I call the police.
They said, No, no way.
I'm telling anybody, don't worry,
you know, and I check the hospitals.
Then a while later,
Amelia I.
My daughter, she
knocked on the door and said, Mommy,
the police are here.
And immediately, my
my heart just hit the floor.
And I was on the phone with his sister,
and she told me, just breathe.
Just breathe.
And I went out and,
you know,
the police were there
and all of my friends
and just the look on their faces
you know, I just knew
and it felt like
forever that they weren't telling me
that, you know, and I was kind of like,
what's crazy? Where is he?
And so then
it was the worst day of my life.
I just started, like,
of course, right now.
And then in the midst of it,
my girls are coming to the door
trying to see if I'm okay.
Because they can hear me.
So I'm trying to say this.
Okay, go back inside.
And then my friend said,
you know, you just
you just have to tell them.
And I just went inside, and I told them,
you know,
girls know Daddy
had an accident and he went to heaven,
but those are our dog. And
my youngest is sort of in shock.
The oldest.
Very, very smart. Very.
I mean,
they're both very close with them,
but she just got very angry
and just started
running around
and pushing everything
off of the countertops.
And, you know, understandably
and I try to give her a hug, said,
I don't want a hug.
I want daddy you know?
She said,
what are we going to do on Father's Day?
I don't want to get married.
He's not going to be there.
And so it's you know, it was hard yeah.
And I had to, you know, just to go ahead,
I was going to say about Raymond,
you know,
I can't imagine your loss
I just want to say that.
And to even have a daughter
looking that far ahead
to her wedding day,
I can't imagine as well.
I want to bring in your attorney,
Robert Zimmerman.
Robert,
we read a little bit of Google statement
saying they have the deepest sympathies
for the family.
But but lay it out for us here.
Why one?
Do you have
any reaction to that statement?
But also,
why are you all suing
Google and specifically for what
Sure.
And thanks for having us.
We are suing essentially
two groups of defendants.
This was a private road
and we are suing those responsible
for the road.
This was a development
that was built about three
or four decades ago.
And when they built that development,
they sold the houses.
But their responsibility
didn't stop there.
They had a responsibility to either
turn the roads over to the North
Carolina Department
of Transportation
or set up
an adequate maintenance program.
And they did neither
And this was a bridge
that no one in
the community
wanted to take responsibility for
with respect to Google.
Google was aware for years
before this incident
that this bridge had collapsed
and there was essentially
a cliff
and a crater in the middle
of a residential neighborhood
for nine years.
There is no good reason
why this could occur.
And we have evidence that
multiple complaints were made to Google
through their Google Maps application,
telling them that this was an issue,
telling them that there were articles
that showed that this bridge was out
and they did nothing
I appreciate
they have sympathy at this time,
but it never should have allowed
it never should have been allowed
to occur for this long.
And Alicia, obviously,
GPS is a major part of anyone's life
who's driving on the roads.
Are you able
do you feel you're able to trust
GPS again?
Or how do you view
whipping that out to use it
now, given what what we're learning here
Well, there's sort of
no other choice
these days rather than to use GPS.
And so I have to use it.
But I'm kind of
cynical, like,
well, just be careful, you know, don't,
you know,
drive off anything that's, you know,
that not there.
I mean, I've got to angry about it,
but I still have to use it.
So it's always in the back of my mind.
But that's the thing is that everybody
trusts it.
And or at least has to rely on it.
So I think that it needs to be safe
or at least
to the best of the makers ability.
Yeah.
Well, Alicia Paxson, Robert Zimmerman,
thank you for joining us, Alicia.
Again, so sorry for your loss.
We'll continue to follow this case.